-You look amazing.
-Thank you.
-This is an incredible outfit.
-Well, I wore it for you.
-Thank you.
-I like a pant suit, but I don't
like it to look so manly.
-Yeah, well, this is not that.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Seth.
-This is not -- no one
would say that about that.
-Thank you.
-Hey, I want to say
congratulations. You --
this is your 10th year
of your television show.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's amazing.
-I got to tell you,
I never thought we would
make it this this far.
-Uh-huh.
-You know, when we first
got started, I said, "All right,
if I'm just on for three years,
you know,
I will mind my own business
and go on about my life."
But it takes so much. You know,
you've been on for years.
-Yeah. But less than you,
I am four years.
-Yeah, but you're a white man.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-I feel like nobody ever
mentions that, and thank you.
-Well, the world
is built for you.
-It is, yes.
-Plus, you're very civilized.
-Yeah, I try to be, yeah.
-And I have my ways about me.
-That are maybe less?
-Well, I'm from Jersey.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, I will say,
and I've done your show, and it
was a delight to be there.
You very much do things
your own way.
I mean, not feel as though
it reminded me
of anything else being there.
-I can't be anything but me.
-Yes, I believe that.
-And the idea that the people
have kept me here
for ten years, I'm like,
"Thank you, people."
You know, thank you.
-Well, your audience,
and I mentioned this last time
you were here, it is a party.
It is filmed in the morning,
and I was in my dressing room
and I felt like
I was above the hottest
nightclub in New York City.
-Yep. That's how we get down.
-Yeah, everybody
really gets down.
And I know you actually went --
you traveled around to celebrate
ten years.
-Yeah.
-Where did you go?
-I still like doing market
visits, you know what I mean?
-So you go to the places
where the people
are watching your shows?
-Touch the people
and see the people
and, you know,
go on the local radio shows
and local television shows.
And then, we have a venue
and I do an evening with Wendy,
which is full of salty jokes
and "Ask Wendy"s and stuff.
But I love to go
where the food is.
-Oh, gotcha.
So when you plan a trip,
do you plan it around --
is that fish?
Oh, okay. Or are you just miming
what it's like when you eat?
-My mouth is watering.
-Oh, it's watering.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's the thing.
When you go to Atlanta,
you know the collard greens
are going to be excellent.
-Gotcha.
-You see?
And I like collard greens,
but I don't like the vein.
-Interesting.
-So you have to go to
the correct spot.
-Oh, because some places
will devein
the collared greens for you?
-Well, like, do you like
a Caesar salad?
-Sure.
-Do you like the vein, that big
fat piece in the middle?
-No, but I didn't know
there was a world
where I couldn't get that.
[ Laughter ]
-You have to meticulously
take your time.
-But you're not --
you're too busy.
You're not taking out the vein
in your own collared greens,
right?
You have somebody else
doing that for you.
-No!
-Really?
-Who do you think I am?!
[ Laughter ]
-Don't take this the wrong way.
You're dressed like a woman
who does not deal with her own
deveining of collared greens.
[ Laughter ]
-I devein
my own collared greens.
-Okay.
-I will not complain.
-Oh, wow, great.
-The same thing with cabbage.
I don't like the vein.
Do you like the vein?
-Again, I'm with you
100 percent on this.
You don't have to ask
for every type of lettuce.
[ Laughter ]
-Well I learned
these little tricks
many, many moons ago
when I was a little girl.
You know, when we'd shop
for fruit during the summer,
and my mother taught me
how to --
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-I got to be honest, based on
the setup of this story,
I have no idea what's
making you laugh.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, devein
the collared greens.
-Okay.
-While she's over, picking
the stems off of the cherries.
-Why wouldn't you --
she would do that at the --
-I come from working class.
Stems cost.
Who eats that?
-Oh, you mean,
because they weigh the stem?
-They weigh the whole cherry.
-Oh, so your mom was taking
the stems off
because she didn't want to pay
for an inedible part
of the cherry?
-Right, and I'm over here with
the collared greens saying,
and we don't want to eat veins.
-Wow.
-Yep.
-So --
[ Cheers and applause ]
So if I go to the grocery store
after the Williams family,
I'm just like,
"There's stems everywhere."
-I've been there.
-You are of course now --
you're different,
congratulations.
Obviously, you're in
a different life right now,
living your best life.
You take vacations.
-I buy the stems and everything.
-You buy the stems.
That's great.
-I can't.
And I pick my own
and devein at home.
-That's nice of you now.
You're paying it forward.